[Música]
y hoy nos vamos directos hasta Perú para
conocer más sobre un caso que enluta al
país 27 mineros perdieron la vida en el
departamento de Arequipa luego de un
incendio en el socavón de la mina se
trata del peor accidente de este tipo en
el país desde el año 2000 para ello
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías Francisco los 27
cuerpos de los mineros fueron
trasladados a la morgue Cuáles son los
resultados de la necropsia y que exigen
los familiares
Buenas noches Rodrigo lo rescatistas
demoraron largas horas en un arduo
trabajo para ubicar los cuerpos la
fiscalía ha revelado que los
trabajadores murieron por intoxicación
de gases producido por un incendio que
consumió material inflamable en el
socavón de la mina
Esperanza uno precisamente los
familiares han señalado que ellos jamás
Fueron informados por la empresa minera
y se sienten indignados porque señalan
que se enteraron de la tragedia a través
de los medios locales y una vez que
este hecho se midatizó recién la
compañía les avisó que había ocurrido un
accidente que había relacionado a 27
trabajadores mineros es así que a ellos
se trasladaron a las instalaciones pero
se quejan que no les permitieron el
acceso Ellos están reclamando que la
empresa minera responda por esa
negligencia y piden que las muertes no
queden impunes al respecto la fiscalía
ha iniciado una investigación y señala
que ha programado en primera
interrogatorio a los funcionarios de
esta compañía minera que fue el sábado
escenario de uno de los mayores
accidentes en minería en este país
precisamente Perú es uno de los mayores
productores de oro en América Latina
y Francisco junto a esto que nos estás
contando qué otras acciones están
tomando las autoridades con la empresa
minera
justamente el Ministerio de energía y
Minas ha suspendido todo tipo de
actividad de esta mina y señala que
mientras no se revisen los protocolos de
seguridad y salud ocupacional No se va a
permitir las actividades han señalado
también que han ubicado accidentes con
muertes de algunos trabajadores en años
anteriores pero de en otras operaciones
en otros escenarios de esta empresa
minera entonces van a fiscalizar que
todo se realiza bien y es precisamente
seguridad y salud ocupacional lo que
vendría a ser uno de los puntos débiles
en las actividades mineras de algunas
compañías antes de este reporte estuve
conversando con algunos especialistas y
ellos me han manifestado que existe
diferente tipo de flaquezas y los
expertos con cifras en mano me han dicho
que el año 2022 38 personas fallecieron
en este tipo de accidentes Mientras que
el año 2021 63 trabajadores murieron al
respecto hay algo que no está marchando
bien y piden que las autoridades
intervengan Mientras tanto en Perú al
sur de los Andes de Arequipa decenas de
familias lloran por sus muertos y
esperan justicia y que esta tragedia no
vuelva a ocurrir nunca más